je pense que c'est un sujet très sérieux
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'on est pleinement mobilisé et
si tous les lycées de la région de
France c'était dans ces talents je pense
que du blablables
c'est que du vent vous brasser que du
vent la réalité c'est ça nos enfants ils
vont à l'école
c'est faux parce que il y a d'autres
problèmes
alors dites-nous c'est quoi les autres
problèmes comme ça le professeur qui ne
sont pas remplacés mon fils a des
dernières étaient en spécialité physique
il n'a pas une prof de physique pendant
trois mois et pas appeler
il y en a pas dans 93 c'est pas vrai
vous êtes pas là vous êtes élus certes
je sais pas qui vous a élu mais il y a
pas d'action pour nous en fait on est
des abandonnés de la République Monsieur
les profs ils sont venus avec des
casseroles devant l'éducation nationale
ils ont rien fait
justement nous la région on demande qui
mettent des moyens en place souvent la
région vient notamment je vous prends
tout à l'heure vous prenez un exemple
les ordinateurs de la région sur
d'autres sujets sur l'insertion
professionnelle sur plein d'autres
sujets on vient en fait faire nous la
région ce que l'État ne fait pas en
réalité et on se mobilise dessus
là vous m'attaquez la politique
politicienne
vous dites c'est normal ça prend du
temps c'est pas possible de prendre du
temps là il faut qu'il y ait un camion
demain qui arrive et puis il faut
attaquer les travaux c'est pour ça
ils sont venus ils ont remis les pâtes
au plafond ils ont changé
[Applaudissements]
qui était PMP pour que tout d'un coup ce
qui prend 5 ans exactement pourquoi
Monsieur
depuis quelques semaines d'ailleurs
ils avancent sur les travaux comme ça
un chantier de rénovation
je comprends je comprends pas vous êtes
un fils d'ouvriers vos enfants sont fils
ouvriers non son fils est un élu ils
sont dans l'école des enfants
j'ai pas encore la chance d'être papa
donc voilà vous pouvez pas parler
moi de deux enfants qui vont dans ce
lycée H24 de 8h jusqu'à 17h30 il n'y a
pas de chauffage il n'y a pas de
toilette il n'y a pas d'eau il n'y a pas
de professeur il n'y a pas de sécurité
il n'y a rien nous sommes abandonnés par
vous les élus de la République je peux
pas vous laisser quand on voit quand on
voit les images on est d'accord
on est en
le carrelage non
[Applaudissements]